Speaker 1: it wasn't just Luke Beasley on the
ground in Pickens, South Carolina, for the Trump
rally. We also have these incredible interviews
done by right wing media, including right side
broadcasting. This one is maybe the sickest. We've
seen. A woman at the Trump rally in South Carolina
said that Biden and others should be taken to
the train station. I There's no way around this,
folks. She's talking about trains to concentration
camps. That's what this woman is talking
about and says it with no shame.
Speaker 4: What should President
Trump do one day? One when he gets back in?
Unidentified: Lock your doors. Lock them all.
Speaker 4: Rally the deep state. Take it down.
Speaker 2: Break it down. And it is taking the
train station.
Speaker 4: Taking the train station.
Speaker 1: I hate to say that that's even almost
too much for Marjorie Taylor Greene's boyfriend,
Brian Glenn, who does these interviews.
This is what Nazis say. Here's a guy at
the Trump rally who told Brian Glenn Trump's
trying to expose the deep state and Lindsey
Graham's part of that deep state, I'm sure.
Speaker 4: First, she got to expose the deep
state, and he's been working on that. And
we don't know. One of the creatures is here,
Lindsey Graham.
Speaker 1: There you go. Brian Glenn
also unsure whether he wants to get involved in
that. Of course, one of the things cultists often
say when they are constantly lied to by the cult
leader is that the cult leader is really honest.
Here's what this woman had to say.
Speaker 2: I think people are becoming
more involved rather than they did before. And
a lot of people's eyes are opening to what is
more truthful and what's not right. Yeah. Yeah,
absolutely. Truth is a revolution right now,
and that's something that we've had in a
long time and it feels good. It's refreshing.
Speaker 1: I think it's refreshing that
Trump is so, so, so honest. So, so,
so honest. And then even interviewing an 11 year
old girl who has been sadly brainwashed with the
same stuff says Trump's the only honest guy left.
Speaker 2: Why are you excited to be here? What
made you want to come out? Because I love Charlie.
What is it that you like about Donald Trump?
He only tells the truth. Oh, that's a
big thing, right? Tell him the truth.
Speaker 1: Scary cult stuff. Scary cult
stuff. We've got a great bonus show for
you today. Sign up for Join PAC Mint.com.
Remember, Alex Jones hates the bonus show.
Speaker 4: The bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody else
who makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Howard Stern likes the bonus show,
but he won't pay for it.
Speaker 4: David Packman
membership because six bucks a month.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Join Pacman. Scott, my
friends. That's the place to sign
up. We'll see you on the bonus show.